In a nutshell,
we take the most useful research from
cognitive science about how the human
brain reasons and makes decisions and
the errors that the human brain tends to
make when reasoning or making decisions
and we turn that research into workshops
that people can use to apply it to their
own lives and improve their own decision
making about their health,
their finances,
their relationships,
and the decisions that they make for the
first society and the world in general
about how to vote and how to treat other
people and what they can do to improve
the world.
One example of rationality and action,
just to give you a sense of what it
looks like and how it's relevant.
Back in 1985,
intel,
uh,
had a,
a large foot in the memory chip
manufacturing business and they'd been
losing money on a memory chips for
years.
So the two co founders,
Andy Grove and Gordon Moore met to
figure out what to do,
uh,
and at one point and he asked what do
you think a new CEO would do if the
board kicked us out and brought in a new
CEO?
And without hesitating,
Gordon replied,
Oh,
he would get out of the memory business
and any,
he said,
well,
so is there any reason we shouldn't do
that if we just walk out the door and
come back in and switch out of the
memory business?
And in fact that's exactly what they've
decided to do.
And it was a huge success.
Um,
and this is just one example of a
cognitive bias that appears in lots of
contexts and lots of scales called the
commitment effect,
where we stick with a business plan or a
career or relationship long after it's
become quite clear that it's not doing
anything for us or that it's actively
destructive or self destructive because
we have an irrational commitment to
whatever we have been doing for a awhile
because we don't like the idea of our
past investments having gone to waste or
because it's become part of our
identity.
And the technique that Andy and Gordon
used to snap themselves out of the
commitment.
The fact is also a really generally
useful technique called looking at a
problem as if you were an outsider,
an outside party over the past few
decades.
Cognitive scientists have learned a lot
about this and many other biases that
human brains are subject to when we try
to make decisions,
but fortunately,
cognitive science has also learned a lot
about things that we can do to improve.
So at the center for applied
rationality,
we're taking that research,
teaching people about the biases where
they occur,
when we're vulnerable to biases,
and then teaching them simple and easy
mental habits like looking at a problem
as if you're an outsider to overcome
those biases.
Rationality also is a significant public
good,
and that's one of the main motivations
behind the founding of CFR.
Society would look very different if
rationality,
rational thinking and decision making
more widespread just to name a few of
many,
many things that I could name.
We as a society would demand evidence
from politicians for the claims that
they made.
We would notice when politicians were
misdirecting us by playing on our
emotions,
we would be less vulnerable to prejudice
and stereotypes.
Um,
because we would be wary of the
confirmation bias,
which is a very universal bias in which
you,
you look for examples,
fit a stereotype,
but you don't look for examples that
don't fit the stereotypes you ended up
confirming and reinforcing a stereotype
in your minds.
We would spend our money much more
effectively as a society to stave off
important risks.
The fact that things like terrorism and,
um,
crimes like abduction are,
uh,
so vividly portrayed on the news makes
them a much more salient and makes us
overweight those risks the same way we
overweight any kind of evidence.
It's particularly vivid or salient.
Um,
even if it isn't actually the best bang
for our buck in terms of risk reduction.